notre monde c'est speed tuba aujourd'hui
on se trouve sur the inq non en bon
français et je propose qu'on quitte le
jeu alors c'est un nouveau jeu
d'équitation même si on dirait pas ceci
est totalement faux c'est un jeu
d'horreur je sais pas du tout ce qu'est
le but mais je vois que la gauche et
marquées or collecter euros sur trois
octaves il faut collecter de l'or
échappe toit du pillage des morceaux qui
est d'accord c'est très bien alors ya
encore fort nuageux pas tourner ce que
je ramassais peut-être une lampe torche
édition collector c'est parti je cause
c'est par là bien évidemment aulas mais
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait cette porte
j'étais séduit et c'est ça calme-toi
puisqu'elle me toi ah non ok en fait
écho en der d'accord on est désormais
dans leur langue
il faut donc aux collectes trois lingots
d'or je suppose et on est a peur 0 sur 8
voit la même chose qu'on habite survie
on décède deux pauvres et si je prenais
cette torche qui éclaire sont en fait
qu'un peu m'expliquer ce qu'il vient de
se passer à ce que je n'ai pas du tout
compris vous êtes mort c'est bon je
compris merci d avoir un piège un truc
j'ai pas fait dire mais on voit que dans
ton jeu assez redoutable ah ça c'est
quand il ya une invasion voilà donc la
deûle avoir une impression de gobelins
je pense au calme et vous qu'allez vous
messieurs c'est sur une marche
tranquillement quand tu dors malgré sa
hausse et quoi c'est des yeux jamais
calme toi hein
première étape baisser le son deuxième
étape retient son 43e et après ce palm
en fait c'étaient des yeux griffey a des
murs et quand je les regarde
j'attrape de la peur est donc là je suis
décidé de peur voilà je dois marcher
comme ça la tête baissée au je suis la
victime du anne-claude j'attrape non
mais attends mais mais j'étais obligé de
lattre deux firent la tombe à la trappe
dès fier de la trappe des bouchons
étaient quoi s'acheter la comparaison de
mof main à toi ya de la lumière qui
jaillit du mur la ya un gros problème
d'avoir la lumière derrière ce mur je
veux aller à semur plus tard coup de
tête coup de tête coûte
attends je suis une blague et quand je
trouve les yeux je suis né céder quoi à
au caire le niveau général at war mans
déjà à y porte
j'aime ça une main qu'est ce que c'est
que ça ah non j'ai attrapé un peu
d'études attend mais laissez-nous
contempler la beauté de l'objet ok faut
juste faire des petits regards aux plats
à botter up la beauté mais c'est
n'importe quoi
regardez moi si je suis enfermé mais
dans bc2 [ __ ] de blague je peux sauter
sur la main [ __ ] lâche-moi m'enfuir
bon ok j'ai obligé de mourir quoi elle
est la plus peur mais si c'est une
blague
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce jeu
d'horreur du mois en plus tu me fait de
l'oeil c'est avec une grande tristesse
que je vous annonce que la maille a
complètement fait cracher mon ordi ben
voilà enfin quelque chose qui nous fait
plaisir jamais été aussi content de te
voir toi tu t'en fous c'est ça non mais
tu ne cotise pas alors qu'est ce qu'on a
olam aaa pas cette fois non je pensais
qu'il a le pied un oeil aussi à non non
mais les cibles justement des patois
[ __ ] je demander à eux
non mais arrête oh je m'envole grâce à
mes narines
non mais sans déconner c'est carrément
un jeu d'hyperactif quoi faut bouger
partout tout le temps pour pas mourir ça
va et oui stellistes imitations et
qualifiés tout se passe bien pour moi on
a fait plus de 20 mètres sans mourir
c'est absolument génial
gauche ou droite droite ça c'est des
pièges en fait ça c'est des pièges voilà
c'est ça qui me tue à chaque fois en
haut des escaliers qui montent
y'a un mec est pas du tout net ici il
jette des corps de mannequin nu vous
avez vu ça se faisait pas peur par
contre ça notre perso il a regardé l'a
fait nous tout va bien sur les risques
aux impôts chocolat bompard compte une
[ __ ] de main en pierre avec un
fauteuil dessus ça il a peur hein j'ai
peur j'ai peur j'ai peur
y'a rien lucas ya rien y'a rien du coup
va recroiser le bade et oui désolé où je
perds marche dessus excuse-moi chasse
aux trésors simulateur 2014 trouve trois
lingots d'or et surtout n'attrape pas
peur ne retient pas
ça monte aussi là mais attends mec mais
ils trouvèrent d'espagnac d'enfants qui
tombe quoi ça suffit ah bah oui je sais
tu vas pas bien je sais bien mais laisse
moi passer au moins égoïste soit trouvé
un lingot d'or sur trois se tient une
belle victoire pour nous
oui y avait vraiment un crâne quoi j'ai
fait un très petit volet quoi j'ai
jamais vu ça de toute ma vie
ce qui est normal si tu avais un crâne
qui bolt va pas très bien tout droit ou
gauche gauche
voilà je la déciderai plus rapide et
voilà comme d'habitude c'est mauvais
gauche ou droite gauche
non non non mais non mais c'est pas vrai
ouais au j'ai maintenant le pouvoir de
la téléportation mère fille jeanne dion
alors il ya des pics donc je pense qu'il
se trouve ça va ça va à temps mais il ya
fear 3 sur wii pourquoi d'abord [ __ ]
ils voient des pics gauche aussi la
question du crâne
oui je passe par dessus oh là là mais il
ya beaucoup de talent cet homme a
beaucoup de talent on a noté un je m'en
vais de l'écran à a pas cette fois non
alors petite anecdote nul à chaque fois
je vois ce mur j'ai l'impression qu'un
chirurgien a tenté lui faire une
césarienne
voilà ça me faisait plaisir de vous
raconter cette petite histoire pendant
qu'on marché de manière éternelle dans
un donjon sans fin qu'est ce que c'est
que ça c'est probablement 1,3 at 1
ne me dites pas qu'il y aura peur en
voyant transat quand même un couloir
long qui s'enchaînent sur une agression
de type crâne volant oh là là là là mais
c'est pas vrai
[ __ ] c'est pas comme si j'avais déjà
vécu ça deux fois de l'or je cherche de
l'or 2 au non non c'est pas de l'or
s'est pas c'est la mort ça je déteste
tous ceux qui ont créé ce jeu savoir un
mec et ces gestes là voilà j'attends ici
patiemment je me mets en position
foetale dans cette offre bon attendez on
n'a pas fait la bise à marianne parfait
et je vais monter ça va tomber
ok nickel mais laisse-moi pas si bien
mais non
l'asie mais voilà le combo mannequin
venue plus tard volant s'est terminée
quand il manquerait plus que la main il
arrivé là c'est le jeu qui développe la
schizophrénie à isabelle au sein pasaop
la petite bise à toi aussi
ah bon le mec je lui fais la bise il le
prend comme ça voilà j'aimerais au moins
trouvé un seul lingots d'or juste un
seul
oh là là non mec non mais non mais non
quoi mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
suit une embuscade
il n'y a pas un truc caché doit avoir de
l'or ici c'est sûr je sais je peux le
sentir dans tes yeux
non pas du tout dans ta bouche ou la
mouche oh oh mon dieu oh la riba
surprise la vilaine à temps mais là on
tient un truc là du sang par exemple
avec un portail non mais attention avec
armand mourir mais c'est sûr je vais
mourir par là par la yes 20ème dites pas
que je me suis bloqué sort d'ici à les
pépins de barils à donne il faut quand
même qu'on fasse quelque chose
le record du monde du plus gros highfive
allen michael voilà c'est tout pour moi
allez juste un peu dehors un petit
lingot d'or
non mais c'est pas vrai dans mon cas je
préfère ne pas aller à la recherche d'or
à ne pas voir aussi des pierres [ __ ]
mais ça va me tuer mais qui est le
coupable
mais c'est le mannequin nu qui se venge
de toutes les fois où il s'est pris la
marche sur la tête quoi ok je suis
confiant sur ce coup je suis confiant ça
fait trois minutes que je suis confiant
mais qu'il ne se passe rien et voilà
c'est la grosse déception et la mort qui
s'ensuit mais j'ai pas réussi à finir
value je suis là je n'ai pas réussi à
trouver à lingots d'or sur les 3 mais un
problème quoi pour qu'on se détendre là
vous comme moi faut qu'on se détendent
bon ben voilà on s'est déjà passé une
vidéo j'espère que vous aura plus il
qu'elle n'était pas aimé ça fait
vraiment plaisir
j'avoue qu'on n'a jamais été aussi nul
sur un jeu d'horreur mais bon non quand
même fait de très belles rencontres un
oui de belles belles rencontres
bonsoir tout un tas de nouvelles vidéos
tient tout le monde non donc tu ne l'a
sûrement pis